thank you
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
nothing can stop me I Can't Get Enough
playing with dangerous
[Applause]
laughs
why are you here I got this situation
where I need your help
I need bad friends
cause I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription oh guys remember this face
oh shoot it by accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
these babies go off
it'll be World War III
to choose this life over friends
over family
time to get loud
let's fly baby
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got
oh it's way bigger than that
all right